if you look towards all of the forms of
entertainment that young men within
modern society today within Western
society today have they're coming up to
a real fundamental decision like bump
commitment marriage let's just talk
about dating if the option is yo I can
go over here and go and see a Call of
Duty LAN party with me and my partners
for the rest of this Friday night and
have a bang up time shooting terrorists
in the head versus going on a date with
a modern woman today these men are
making rational decisions there are men
that are making rational decisions of
should I stay in tonight beat off to the
hub instead of going out and deal with
the mouth of a modern woman